as like any e-commerce company should I
do and when you like constantly optimize
the conversion rates like as we think
about the kit as we think about the
purchase flow and because in traditional
e-commerce when you have like a visitor
come to your page and a visitor actually
checking out it's just like a really big
drop-off anywhere from ninety percent to
ninety eight percent depending on the
e-commerce site and this is because
people like there's a lot of different
carriers and I'm like in that process as
you're sort of trying to understand what
type of product do I want what's up a
color what type of size now I have to
put it all my address information and
payment information and so we constantly
try to like optimize that experience
like to make it as like easy as possible
and making it as few clicks and things
people are typing in and so on an
example of that was as we're thinking
about all right so we have we had people
coming in to teespring and and they want
to like and they've already purchased
from us before what is a way we can make
that process easier for them like to
actually be able to then just like
import all their all their previous
address information and so this was like
a feature which we hadn't ever built
prior and so like as we looked at this
like one of the things that we really
wanted optimized for was around was
around speed and especially for people
like on their devices like on their
phones like being able to type in like a
lot of fields is is like really painful
and so like that's just one example of
how we kind of like try to optimize for
this is to say that like if you're a
buyer who's come to TSP before what are
the different ways like we can actually
import import like your previous
information into the checkout experience